a huge explosion mass casualties people
rushed to hospital
[Music]
chaotic scenes in the midst of a chaotic
evacuation
the threat level had been high for days
and days at the canal that leads to the
british camp
the sheer volume of people the lack of
checks of bags and the numbers of
unprotected soldiers were an absolute
indicator that this place was the
easiest of easy targets
we filmed here for days
now it has happened
from within these crowds a suicide
bomber
the civilian casualty numbers are high
it was always going to be
so unprotected and desperate to leave
they wouldn't have noticed anyone acting
strangely because here everyone is
acting strangely it's an emergency
a variety of international soldiers have
been looking for people with a right of
entry to their countries some had
already withdrawn because of the threat
but the united states and british forces
do not have that luxury
the paratroopers have been fully engaged
in the processing of the evacuees in
this area but their main focus is on the
sea containers that limit the numbers
trying to get through
slightly further up the road on the side
of the sewage field canal
the americans were basically in charge
we've been told the bomber waited until
a number of soldiers approached to help
a family out of the canal
the taliban have been cooperating with
the international forces for days now
this will do nothing for them and they
have condemned the attacks targeting
innocent
civilians is an act of terrorism that
has to be condemned by the entire world
it is because of foreign forces the
presence of foreign forces that such
attacks take place
afghanistan's future already uncertain
keeps changing
airports are hard to defend because
they're so huge
this evacuation relief effort is
potentially about to end stuart ramsey
sky news doha